what up space fam goes in here from
anime up pro
and after the reveal that zeke is still
alive in the anime
i felt like it was the perfect time to
discuss what's going on with zeke
and what his true master plan is if you
do enjoy seeing these attack on titan
videos and want to keep them coming then
the best thing you could do
is warhammer smash that like button and
share this video with any attack on time
fans that you know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select all or you will miss
future attack on time videos and while
you wait for the next video to drop
feel free to check out my growing attack
on titan playlist where we got videos
about all the titan shifters and their
powers
all the acronyms and their powers the
titans ranked from weakest to strongest
and much more
link to that is in the description now
without further ado
let's jump into it spoilers and all so
what is zeke's true plan
recently in the final anime season of
attack on titan zeke seemingly got
wrecked by levi
marley's strongest warrior seemed to be
itching to face levi again
only to get taken out before anyone even
realized what was happening
it seemed anticlimactic because these
guys were set up with arguably the best
rivalry in the series
humanity's strongest soldier on the one
end versus the strongest warrior on the
other
so many anime only watchers must have
been left pretty speechless after this
however that can't be the end of the
beast titan that would be
too easy too simple and not very
satisfying and accordingly
we end up seeing zeke on the airship and
we find out that the soldier that was
guiding peak and porco to the trap was
actually one of zeke's followers
so we find out that zeke faked his death
and actually
appears to be on the side of parodies
now after the time skip even after he
killed so many survey corps members when
he was on the island the jaeger brothers
finally appeared to be on the same side
even humanity's strongest soldier and
marley's strongest warrior
seem to be on the same side and the main
question is
why how could the guy who acted like he
was playing a carefree game of baseball
when he was murdering so many people on
parody's island
be the same guy that now seemingly
betrayed his own side
to help the people of parodies island
did he have a change of heart or is this
all part of his master plan that he had
from the beginning
that's what we're going to be exploring
in this video and at the end of it
you will understand not only what zeke
wants and why but also how he plans on
getting it done
when gabby and falco see him on the
airship they are
shocked wondering how they managed to
catch their captain and warchief but
this misunderstanding is cleared up when
hanji asks and i quote
so would you say that everything went
according to plan zeke yeager end quote
this is one of the craziest twists in
attack on titan and it must be one of
the craziest twists in the lives of
gabby and falco
these two just experienced an
unprecedented attack
where two of their close friends died
along with many others only to find out
that it was their leader's plan
zeke does not try to explain or pretend
like he's still on their side he just
calls them miscalculation
showing that he doesn't really care
about them except for what they mean to
his master plan and they're not
important pieces
either but just hiccups later on it is
revealed why
zeke and aaron needed to get together as
he said
and i quote now we have both the
founding titan and a titan of royal
blood meaning himself all of your
precious sacrifices will bear fruit
aldia will be free end quote so at this
point it seems that zeke's plan is to
help make ldf free which sounds great
but is this another lie
or if not what does freedom for aldians
look like for zeke
whatever the plan aaron and zeke the
jaeger bros
seem to be on the same page for now
together with zeke's royal blooded titan
and with
aaron's founding titan that is not
limited by carl fritz's pacifist
ideology
the two have godlike power at their
disposal we're talking the power to
rewrite
ldn memories change the body composition
of all aldeans awaken and control the
tens of millions of colossal titans
within the walls
and so on but again we gotta figure out
how zeke plans to use this godlike power
zeke was the one who sent devout
followers of his
like yelena to help paradise island and
make aaron's mission in marley possible
to carry out in the first place
yelena explains to levi and the rest
that zeke's request is for them to
accept him onto their island for the
remainder of the time he has left
remember that his time is running out
because of amir's curse
which gives titan shifters only 13 years
to live
after inheriting a titan power zeke
wants to then be taken to his
half-brother aaron yeager the possessor
of the founding titan if the people
of the island meet these conditions he
guarantees paradise's safety
and will provide them with the latest
technology and weapons he will serve as
a mediator between the island and other
friendly nations and he'd also do more
he'd do all this to help rescue
the aldean people whose existence is
being threatened especially with the
fast advancements being made in aerial
warfare
zeke says there's a secret plan that can
be carried out that will solve all of
the eldian people's problems at once
and all it needs to be carried out is
the founding titan
and a titan with royal blood zeke
promises that the world can be saved
with those two things
aaron upon hearing this confirms that
zeke speaks the truth in the sense that
the one time he was able to activate the
founding titan he did it when he touched
a titan with royal blood
specifically the dean of fritz titan aka
zeke's titan mom
during the flashback of what happened
during the time skip arid spoke with
mikasa
armin about the importance of buying
time to ensure the advancement of
paradise technology
and positive relations between other
nations and aaron decided that he was
going to buy that time
to keep their enemies from messing with
paradise island and that decision
culminated in the assault we witnessed
on marley
even armin who hates violence said that
if the marlan port had been left
intact marlei would have launched an
immediate counter-attack on the island
so they had no choice but to do what
they did
which included destroying marley
battleships and ending many lives in the
process
this all arguably wouldn't have happened
if it wasn't for zeke's secret plan
that inspired aaron to take unilateral
action in order to make contact with his
half-brother
zeke ends up telling the azumabito
family that what he secretly wants is to
realize the restoration
of the glorious eldian empire like his
father did but as a kid when he found
out that the marlenes were on to the
other elder restorationists he made the
decision
to turn them in so he wouldn't be killed
and could go on pursuing his goal
as an alden restorationist however this
wasn't true either
things happen in between like aaron's
warhammer jailbreak
and zeke making sure his spinal fluid
gets consumed through wine by many
aldians so that he could scream
and turn them into titans he could
control when the time finally came
zeke also gets himself blown up and
permanently injures levi in the process
but zeke manages to survive because a
nearby titan takes him into its body
where his own body gets regenerated we
see amir the founding titan working to
construct his body in the unknown land
that connects all eldians because he has
royal blood
and as we eventually find out emir has
been serving the royal family
practically forever
from this land as a kind of slave but it
is right before this self-explosion and
encounter with emir that we get a
flashback in the manga to the previous
beast titan user
tong xaver who was like a father figure
to zeke
he did not adopt his true father's
philosophy but rather
tom's when tom's wife found out he was
an aldian
she killed herself and their son not
surprisingly
this devastated tom tom felt like it
would have been better
if he were never born and zeke agreed
and planned to inherit the beast titan
and use it to execute his plan
he'll use the founding titan power to
save the world by freeing the people of
the world from their fear of the titans
and freeing aldeans from their suffering
his idea of freedom was using the
founding titan's power to change the
body composition of all
aldeans so they can no longer have
children and so aldians and by extension
titans will eventually die out
in zeke's view death is a kindness for
aldians
if you ask him everyone he killed he
saved from this cruel world
and by making it so no audience could
have kids he would be saving their
future kids from this cruel world as
well
for him as with tom the greater good is
never suffering in this world
rather than being born and inevitably
suffering in it
this is such a pessimistic view of the
world and it was hard for me to believe
that aaron would go along with such a
plan what gives zeke the right to decide
whether other people's lives are worth
living or not
deciding for himself is one thing but
it's ridiculous for him to think that he
can rightfully wipe out all
ldn people just because he thinks it's
what's best for them
aaron was the one who was always talking
about the importance of fighting on and
moving forward even when things seemed
bad so is it possible that he could
actually go along with such a plan which
basically
translates to giving up on life
eventually when aaron and zeke make
contact
we figure out the truth they meet in the
unknown land and zeke appears to be
chained these chains are supposed to
represent karl firtz's ideology which
keeps royal-blooded people
from fully using the founding titan
power zeke tells aaron to make their
dream a reality to tell
emir to give every ld in a body that
will never again be capable of creating
children
but aaron refuses to euthanize every
eldian
saying there's no way he could ever
agree with such a messed up plan
he was only playing along with zeke's
plan so he could gain this ultimate
power and save his people the aliens on
paradise island when zeke asks aaron why
aaron responds because i was born into
this world and in his view he wasn't
born into this world
and his fellow aldians weren't born into
this world just to take themselves out
of it
zeke however accounted for this in his
plan too the chains were actually fake
and he was just testing aaron as zeke
reveals
he's the one with royal blood and amir
serves as a kind of mindless slave to
the royal family
and zeke arrived to this place without
being tainted by the first king's
ideology so he was able to nullify the
effects
that would prevent him from using the
founding titan to the fullest
at this point zeke reveals that aaron
was his key to unlocking this power and
using it to carry out his plan
and it might have worked too if it
wasn't for aaron being able to release
emir from her brainwashing aaron saw
amir the girl that became the first ever
titan for the human she was
and made her use her free will and with
it emir decided to support
aaron while zeke was seemingly absorbed
into aaron's giant founding titan body
and as of now aaron has access to zeke's
beast titan power
as he is carrying out his plan to
flatten the earth with the tens of
millions of colossal titans so that his
people
the aldeans on the island will finally
be able to live in peace without having
to live in fear of being wiped out
so zeke's philosophy and thought process
was that so long as there are eldians
this hell will never
end the bloodshed would never stop what
they've repeated so many times will only
continue for eternity
so zeke's plan was to end this hell and
the cycle of violence by ending the
existence of the aldians
however aaron decided that he would end
the cycle by wiping out all the people
who wanted his people dead
once and for all and he's the one who's
currently carrying out that plan while
armin and the rest
want some sort of middle way they'd
rather let the cycle continue for now
while slowly trying to change the way
people view each other
and their need for revenge armin's plan
is the least defined and definitive of
them all
and in aaron's view it is naive because
it also allows the enemy time to finally
eliminate them but that plan does
leave room at least for a possible world
where people can eventually forget and
or move beyond
the grudges of the past and live in
peace with each other let me know your
thoughts do you empathize with zeke
aaron or armin the most or do you think
they all came up with deeply flawed
plans
and do you think there's another
solution that none of them thought of
yet
and let me know how you think this story
is going to end but yeah that is it for
zeke's true plan with info about aaron's
plan and armin's less defined plan all
thrown in
one thing's for sure nothing is black
and white in attack on titan
and none of these plans come without
their problems and that's one of the
ways attack on titan stands out compared
to a lot of other anime
especially shonen because it refuses to
give you an evidently right decision
like most shonen series do
usually you have a character who has a
goal of being the best at something and
they move towards that goal while being
a moral person and never giving up
the view of being able to reach your
goal while not staining your soul
and also acting morally throughout the
process clearly doesn't seem possible
in the attack on titan world even armin
as mentioned who is arguably the closest
person to a usual shonen protagonist
acknowledged that he had no choice but
to kill soldiers
and even innocent people at one point i
can't wait to see
how this series ends and what view the
story ends up leaning towards although
it is most likely in the case of attack
on titan that there will be
no final right answer people have always
known including the oldest philosophers
that human life goes hand in hand with
suffering and
everyone has the free will to decide for
themselves how to act in the face of
that sometimes cruel reality but that is
it for this one
if you did enjoy this video or got some
value from it make sure to let me know
by
smashing that like button if you haven't
be sure to subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell and select
all or you will miss future attack on
time videos and while you wait for the
next attack on titan video to drop
feel free to check out our growing
attack on time playlist where we got
videos about all the time shifters and
their powers all the acronyms and their
powers the times ranked for weakens the
strongest and much more
link to that is in the description and i
especially want to thank the patron
squad over on patreon and here on
youtube who helped make videos like this
one possible
first and foremost i want to thank the
patron of legend the one acknowledged by
lord tuigo himself and the most donated
champion of the world alpha sigma
and are the one tier patrons the ones
who stand atop all clans in grata the
world
acquire respect pate heffa liam thompson
al-jatal
dr cortman johnny boyd draws emperor
otaku spidey life tinel baked buddhist
and tungsten tarkis
and are pro hero to your patrons the one
and only gilgamesh steelers angel crews
anatoly kazatsky
joe stanton very gucci jessica kayla
fond rathu and aura
alicia actor bonnie parks hinokami and
water the red-haired raven joanne garcia
jack watches anime fat boy games deadly
saint matthew cruz
and anthony schreiber thank you all so
much if you enjoy our work you can
support more of it by going over to
patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these
epic people right here and you'll even
get access to our private patron only
discord where we talk about anime life
and of course
dank memes so check out patreon.com
anime upload link in the description if
you're interested you can also join the
youtube channel by clicking that blue
join button next to the subscribe button
that you've hopefully
already destroyed so yeah you could
support work on that way if you prefer
and whichever way you choose to support
us you can get the same
great benefits thanks again and until
next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you